i would like to see you know governor  desantis or someone like that some some  new blood in in the race desantis  run for president and if he wants to  then he can pick up donald as the vice  president we're from florida um  desantis is we're big fans of desantis  on this one he seems to be much more  common sense  and able to communicate better to both  sides  to get those people back then  so remember they could have picked  anybody they could interview that  they're only including a few people in  this they could have interviewed 50 or  60 or 70 people and gotten whatever they  wanted everybody's saying trump should  run or not everybody's saying to santa  they have chosen these people to create  this story